Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a Chinese sci-fi
film called “The Revenge Of Plant.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins at the university of Qingshan.
Professor Huo Yuchun and his assistant Zheng
Wen are teaching a class about genetic engineering.
The students take pictures of the board to
go through the notes later.
One of them, named Luo Ke, takes a picture
of Zheng Wen instead.
She has had a crush on him since she was a
freshman but has never had the courage to
confess.
Luo ke’s best friend Lili shows her the
picture of a freshman’s dead body that was
found in their college that morning.
They dismiss it as a rumor and continue with
the class.
Somewhere else, the police take pictures of
the student who died mysteriously.
His body has turned green almost as if he
was drugged.
When everyone leaves the class, Luo ke hands
Zheng Wen a plant and confesses her love for
him.
Zheng Wen, however, rejects her because she
is his student.
Luo ke expresses her frustration to Lili and
says that she has never been rejected before.
Her friend suggests she let it go and makes
her dance to a song playing on the radio.
Zheng Wen sees them dancing and smiles to
himself.
Following that, Luo ke’s classmate who is
in love with her approaches her with a bouquet
of flowers.
Lili leaves them alone and goes to her dorm
room.
To her surprise, her face is covered with
green pimples that look like budding plants.
She quickly covers them with makeup.
Luo ke rejects the guy and makes her way to
the dorm room.
Meanwhile, Zheng Wen and professor Huo Yuchun
are in the professor’s office.
The professor offers him a drink that makes
him go unconscious.
Then he brings out a strange plant with glowing
roots and injects a liquid extracted from
it, into Zheng Wen’s body.
He is trying to see if Zheng Wen’s body
is suitable for the plant to grow inside it,
but the match comes out zero percent.
The professor leaves the plant and Zheng Wen
in his office and disappears.
Back in the dorm room, Luo ke notices Lili
acting weird and asks her what is wrong.
Lili doesn’t show her face and just says
that she needs to rest for a while.
Luo ke doesn’t disturb her and starts to
paint a picture of Zheng Wen.
His balcony is visible from their window which
gives Luo ke inspiration for the painting.
Somewhere else in the hostel, a girl hops
in the shower.
Above her, a Creeping plant slowly covers
the showerhead.
When she notices it, the water turns green,
making her scream.
After Luo ke is done with the painting she
decides to give it to Zheng Wen.
But when she knocks on his doors, no one answers.
Just then, a woman named Shu ManLuo approaches
her and brings out a key from under the mat.
She unlocks the door and asks her to wait
inside.
At the same time, Zheng Wen wakes up in the
professor’s cabin.
He is confused as to why he fell asleep but
doesn’t think much of it.
He takes the plant and returns to his room.
As the girls wait, Shu ManLuo reveals that
she is Zheng Wen’s ex-girlfriend and they
went to university together.
Luo ke is hit with a pang of jealousy but
she doesn’t say anything.
Shu ManLuo leaves after a while asking Luo
ke to tell Zheng Wen she was here.
After she leaves, Luo ke goes through Zheng
Wen’s belongings and tries different passwords
for his computer.
Soon after, he arrives and is shocked to see
her inside the room.
Luo ke tells him how she got inside and asks
him why her birthdate is the password to his
computer.
Zheng Wen pretends to not know what she is
talking about, so Luo ke also shows him a
picture of her and Lili on his computer.
He takes her to his balcony and shows her
the plants she has given him throughout the
years.
Zheng Wen then brings up Shu ManLuo and explains
how he was in love with her but she got an
offer to work for a foreign company and dumped
him.
Luo ke tries to hide her jealousy but fails.
She runs away from him but he catches up and
says that he, too, likes her but since they
are teacher and student, he thought the relationship
wouldn’t be appropriate.
Luo ke suggests they date after she graduates
and Zheng Wen agrees.
He gives her the plant that he had gotten
from the professor’s office as a token of
promise.
After returning to her room, Luo ke waters
the plant but the leaves cut her finger in
the process.
She simply puts a bandaid over it while talking
to Lili.
When her friend doesn’t reply, she assumes
that she slept early and goes to sleep herself.
The roots of the plant start to glow in the
dark.
Its branches crawl down to the floor and take
over Luo ke’s bed, strangling her in the
process.
Luo ke wakes up to realize that it was just
a bad dream.
Then, she notices green liquid dripping from
Lili’s bed.
She carefully removes the curtains and discovers
Lili’s dead body.
Her back had started to grow plants from it.
The sight makes Luo ke scream in fear.
Soon, the news travels around and the police
are called to investigate.
Zheng Wen finds out about the incident and
runs to see if Luo ke is okay.
The police officer shows Zheng Wen a plant
that was found in Lili’s body and asks for
his expert advice.
Zheng Wen is confused because the plant looks
like a gymnosperm but has a kind of root that
he has never seen in his life.
While waiting for the police to get done,
Luo ke sees Shu ManLuo in the crowd.
Zheng Wen then takes her to the canteen to
feed her something since she hasn’t eaten
since the morning.
It is announced that the university premises
will go into a complete lockdown because of
a virus that has been discovered in some of
the students.
All the students and teachers are asked not
to leave the university without permission.
When Luo ke and Zheng Wen walk out of the
building, Luo ke hallucinates about plants
taking over the university but quickly comes
back to reality.
At the cafeteria, they hear the news about
professor Huo’s disappearance.
He is accused of endangering public health
by introducing his students to a deadly virus.
Luo ke remembers that Lili has a boyfriend
who she called “H” who helped her pay
for her tuition.
She believes that H had to do something with
her death.
She then goes to the washroom where the bandaid
from her finger moves showing that the cut
has started to grow a plant out of it.
She panics and plucks it out.
A man in a PPE set and a face mask approaches
her and Zheng Wen and asks them to go to the
gymnasium as soon as possible to get tested
and decontaminated.
An announcement is made throughout the university
asking everyone to gather in the gymnasium.
Policemen surround the premises wearing poison
masks which scares the students even more.
On their way to the gymnasium, they come across
Shu ManLuo who reveals that she is a professional
called to investigate the cases of infection.
She represents a multi-millionaire pharmaceutical
company and has been working closely with
professor Huo for a synthetic gene reorganization
research project.
She found out that the professor’s experiments
deviated from the scientific research ethics.
He started to reorganize animal genetics and
plant genetics to create harmful viruses.
When she confronted him, he dismissed her
and didn’t stop the experiments.
He even started to use his students as test
subjects which caused the outbreak of the
virus.
As Shu Manlou and Zheng Wen talk about the
experiments, Luo ke notices her nerves turning
green.
She registers that she has been infected by
the virus and runs away to hide.
Zheng Wen notices after some seconds and starts
to look for her.
Meanwhile, the girl who was attacked by plants
earlier is restrained by the officers for
being infected.
She is given medical assistance but the virus
kills her eventually.
Zheng Wen goes to his room and finds Luo Ke
there.
She asks him to stay away and shows him the
infected arm.
He also notices that her face is glowing green.
Luo ke then opens Lili’s myspace and reads
the notes that she used to write every day.
The note mentions a man named H who used to
take her to his house that had the view of
a lighthouse.
She also talks about a plant that H gave her
as a gift.
They assume that H is none other than professor
Huo himself.
Just then, some men in PPE suits come to the
dorms to disinfect the hallways.
They ask anyone who is still inside the room
to come out.
Zheng Wen and Luo ke are scared that if they
find out Luo ke is infected, they will make
her the test subject of their experiments.
Therefore they decide to hide until the men
leave.
However, Luo ke accidentally drops a glass
of water and gives away their presence.
The men take both of them to the gymnasium
to test them.
After finding out that Luo ke is infected,
they sedate her with a tranquilizer and take
her away.
Later, a group of officials interrogates Shu
Manlou about the virus.
She briefs them that the virus can affect
a human’s brain and nervous system.
However, it isn’t contagious and can only
transmit through direct contact with the infected
plant.
The officials assume that this means the cases
of infection are similar to poisoning and
there is nothing to worry about.
According to Shu Manlou, Luo ke’s genetics
are very well matched to give rise to a new
form of a variable of the virus that might
be extremely dangerous even though it is not
contagious.
The men do not take her warnings seriously
and decide that they are going to lift the
lockdown.
Outside, Zheng Wen meets Shu Manlou and the
two decide to go to the place that Lili talked
about in her journal.
They assume that the place is the professor’s
lab where they can find more information about
the experiments he performed on the students.
They finally reach the house and see it has
been taken over by the plants.
The professor is sitting motionless on a chair.
When the two approach him, a gigantic venus
fly trap emerges from his back and almost
kills them.
Shu Manlou lights the plant on fire and kills
the professor alongside it.
Then, she goes through the professor’s computer
and finds out that if the virus’s growing
condition matches 100% with someone’s genetics,
it will give rise to a never-dying plant that
will grow at an exponential rate and can cover
cities, if not countries.
Similarly, if zero percent of the genetics
match, then the person would be immune to
the virus altogether.
At the beginning of the movie, Zheng Wen’s
genetics had matched zero percent, explaining
the reason he hasn’t been infected, even
though the professor injected him with the
virus directly.
Shu Manlou tries to retrieve data from the
computer to send it back to the company she
works for.
Zheng Wen is against it since a lot of people
have died because of the experiment and the
information might put more lives in danger.
When he stops her, Shu Manlou attacks him
with pepper spray.
But before she can run away, a branch grows
from the Venus flytrap and kills her.
Back in the gymnasium, we see that Luo ke’s
genetics have matched hundred percent suitable
for the virus’s growth.
Like the professor had predicted, she starts
to grow a never-ending dense crawler plant
from her body and takes over the gymnasium.
The medical professionals helping her are
also killed in the process.
When Zheng Wen returns to the university,
he finds everyone dead but Luo ke is nowhere
to be found.
We are then shown that the entire city has
been taken over by the plant.
Several months after the incident, Zheng Wen
returns to the university still looking for
Luo ke.
He notices the painting that she made of him
on the classroom’s wall.
In the last scene, Zheng Wen looks behind
and smiles, presumably because he saw Luo
ke.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.